what a night what a debate we have the
first national presidential debate
between Republican Donald Trump and
Democrat Hillary Clinton in the books
and it was extraordinary we're going to
go through the best moments we're going
to go through the worst moments we're
going to go through the many many many
lies that were told by Donald Trump
let's take it from the beginning Donald
Trump's performance yesterday at this
debate basically made Saturday Night
Live irrelevant because between the lies
and the interruptions and the bizarre
water drinking and sniffing and exhaling
and everything that he was doing
seemingly unable to avoid interrupting
Hillary Clinton I don't know how you
pair it parody it it is really
indistinguishable from a parody of
itself let's start right at the
beginning Donald Trump coming out strong
with some ridiculous statements about
the corporate tax rate and Ronald Reagan
take a look under my plan I'll be
reducing taxes tremendously from 35% to
15% for companies small and big
businesses that's going to be a job
creator like we haven't seen since
Ronald Reagan it's going to be a
beautiful thing to watch companies will
come they will build they will expand
new companies will start and I look very
very much forward to doing it we have to
renegotiate our trade deals so I'm
starting with this because unlike most
of the debate Donald Trump actually
proposed something specific
unfortunately there's no evidence
whatsoever that reducing the corporate
income tax rate creates jobs further the
corporate income tax rate doesn't
account for loopholes and deductions and
exclusions and other mechanisms that
lead to corporations already paying no
taxes President Obama's two terms have
actually outperformed Ronald Reagan in
terms of job creation and in terms of
lower unemployment rates so really what
Trump should have said although
politically it wouldn't have been too
smart is I'm going to do even better
than President Obama at creating jobs
who has seen record job growth for
something approaching 80 months does
anybody care I don't know but Trump's
starting off with actual policy ideas as
simplistic as it is to say I'm gonna
reduce the corporate tax rate and it
made no sense then Donald Trump said hey
you know what maybe we should blame
Hillary Clinton for everything all right
you have two minutes on the same
question to defend tax increases on the
wealthiest Americans Secretary Clinton
to be blamed for everything that's ever
why not yeah you know just just just
joined join the debate by saying more
crazy things companies bring their money
back into this is a secretary Clinton's
two minutes please right yeah well let's
start the clock again Lester yeah let's
start that clock right over again the
implosion beginning right I mean Donald
Trump really starting to be clearly
unable to avoid taking the bait from
Hillary Clinton and then this topic of
the Trump tax returns came up in Hillary
Clinton's emails and Trump both confused
about the definition of negotiable and
also in a complete non sequitur tying
his tax returns which we've seen from
every major presidential candidate in
the last 40 years to Hillary Clinton's
emails take a look I will release my tax
returns against my lawyers wishes yeah
when she releases her 33,000 emails that
have been deleted as soon as she
releases them I will release I will
release my tax returns and that's
against my lawyers they say don't do it
I will tell you this you know in fact
watching shows reading the papers almost
every lawyer says you don't release your
returns until the audits complete oh
yeah completely I'll do it but I would
go against them if she releases her it's
negotiable it's not negotiable no let
her release the even why did she delete
33,000 yeah no it's not negotiable but
it kind of is because depending on I am
willing to change what I originally said
based on what Hillary Clinton does this
is what we call negotiation then Hillary
Clinton speculated about why Trump
wouldn't release the tax returns it's
exactly what we've been suggesting why
won't he release his tax returns and I
think there may be a couple of reasons
first maybe he's not as rich as he says
he is second maybe he's not as
charitable as he claims to be
mm-hmm third we don't know all of his
business dealings but we have been told
through investigative reporting that he
owes about 650 million dollars to Wall
Street and foreign banks or maybe he
doesn't want the American people all of
you watching tonight to know that he's
paid nothing in federal taxes because
the only years that anybody's ever seen
were a couple of years when he had to
turn them over to state authorities when
he was trying to get a casino license
and they showed he didn't pay any
federal income tax so zero that means
zero for troops zero for vets zero for
schools or health and I think probably
he's not all that enthusiastic about
having the rest of our country see what
the real reasons are because it must be
something really important even terrible
that he's trying to hide and the
financial disclosure statement they
don't give you the tax rate they don't
give you all the details that tax
returns would and it just seems to me
that this is something that the American
people deserve to see and I have no
reason to believe that he's ever going
to release his tax returns because
there's something he's hiding a very
very strong moment for Hillary Clinton
clear specific concise and Donald Trump
with this interjection that it makes him
smart not to pay federal taxes which is
being seen by many as an admission that
yes indeed he is not paying federal
taxes or at least has not in several it
during numerous individual years which
we already suspect and this total
non-sequitur with the emails very bad
moment for Trump very good moment for
Hillary Clinton okay then this is just a
weird thing Donald Trump mentioning
LaGuardia Airport in New York City as a
third world country why is that
interesting I'll tell you in a second
what
we have 20 trillion dollars in debt and
our country's a mess you know it's one
thing to have 20 trillion in debt and
our roads are good and our bridges are
good and everything's in great shape our
airports our airports are like from a
third-world country
you land at LaGuardia you land at
Kennedy you land at LAX you land at
Newark and you come in from Dubai and
Qatar and you see this incredible you
come in from China
you see these incredible airports and
you land we've become a third world
country so why is that weird well it's
weird because Joe Biden said the exact
same thing years ago about LaGuardia
Airport and he was absolutely absolutely
destroyed for it by Republicans take a
look we have the video of Joe and said
where do you think you are this must be
America's a modern Airport if I took him
blindfolded you took the LaGuardia
Airport in New York you must think I
must be in some third-world country yeah
so very strange I don't know where he
got the idea that it would be good to
repeat that line from Joe Biden but very
very strange moment and here's one of my
favorite moments that really epitomize
the entire debate Donald Trump went on a
rant about supposed quote law and order
this was an utter disaster circular
talking going absolutely nowhere and
Hillary Clinton standing aside and
giving Trump all the rope he needed to
hang himself in this just never-ending
infinite circle of nonsense
well first of all Secretary Clinton
doesn't want to use a couple of words
and that's law and order and we need law
and order if we don't have it we're not
gonna have a country and when I look at
what's going on in Charlotte a city I
love a city where I have investments
when I look at what's going on
throughout various parts of our country
whether it's I mean I can just keep
naming them all day long we need law and
order in our country and I just got
today the as you know the endorsement of
the Fraternal Order of Police we just
just came in
we have endorsements from I think almost
every police group very I mean a large
percentage of them in the United States
we have a situation where we have our
inner cities african-americans Hispanics
are living in hell because it's so
dangerous you walk down the street you
get shot in Chicago they've had
thousands of shootings thousands since
January first
thousands of shootings and I'm saying
where is this is this a war-torn country
what are we doing and we have to stop
the violence we have to bring back law
and order in a place like Chicago where
thousands of people have been killed
thousands over the last number of years
in fact almost 4,000 have been killed
since Barack Obama became president over
4
almost 4,000 people in Chicago have been
killed we have to bring back law and
order until he mentioned Obama in the
last few seconds there I was wondering
what on earth is this a critique of what
is Trump's plan what point is he trying
to make what is the path forward just a
never-ending rant and he said at the
beginning I could name cities all day
long just naming cities he's aware of
would have been a stronger response than
repeating law and order for two minutes
okay
Kiera's Trump's first reference to
Hillary's health it did nothing for him
take a look
I just left Detroit and I just left
Philadelphia and I just you know you've
seen me I've been all over the place you
decided to stay home and that's okay but
I will tell you I've been all over and
I've met some of the greatest people
I'll ever meet within these communities
and they are very very upset with what
their politicians have told them and
what their politicians have done
I think I think that I think Donald just
criticized me for preparing for this
debate and yes I did and you know what
else I prepared for I prepared to be
President and I think that's a good
thing another terrible moment for Trump
and then it got completely bizarre and
sideshow in nature Trump suggesting that
maybe a 400-pound dude on a bed is
actually responsible for recent hacking
I don't think anybody knows it was
Russia that broke into the DNC she's
saying Russia Russia Russia but I don't
maybe it was I mean it could be Russia
but it could also be China it could also
be lots of other people it also could be
somebody sitting on their bed that
weighs 400 pounds okay you don't know
who broke in to DNC but what did we
learn with D and C we learned that
Bernie Sanders was taken advantage of
yeah so lastly and then I want to move
on to looking at some of there's the
flat-out lies Trump told lastly here is
may be the strangest comment of the
entire debate from Trump about his son
being so good with computers so cyber
warfare or something I have a son he's
10 years old he has computers he is so
good with these computers it's
unbelievable yeah the security aspect of
cyber is very very tough and maybe it's
it's hardly doable
right but I will say we are not doing
the job we should be doing but that's
true throughout our whole governmental
society we have so many things that we
have to do better Lester and certainly
cyber is one of them we absolutely need
to be cyber better and Donald Trump's
world as president ok so totally
hilarious and outrageous and it made no
sense and the debate performance was a
disaster but next I want to talk about
Donald Trump's lies